zaher al zaher à 23 ans photo
journaliste syrien il est arrivé en
france il ya un an jour pour jour devant
deux classes de première du lycée van
gogh à aubergenville il est venu
témoigner de son parcours mais aussi de
la difficulté d'exercer son métier en
syrie n'y a pas d'organisme officiel il
ya les forces fidèles au régime et la
société civile
elle est complètement libre et à
elle-même et du coup on sait la marche
et journaliste engagé depuis le début de
la guerre
alzner est intervenue dans le cadre de
l'opération renvoyer spécial un
dispositif organisé par le ministère de
l'éducation nationale et la maison des
journalistes
cette association unique au monde
accueille accompagne des professionnels
de l'information contraints de fuir leur
pays
la situation de la presse en syrie est
un moment très dangereuse donc les
journalistes les activistes comme ça
elles qui ont documenté ce qui s'est
passé ainsi ligne dans leur pays
donc dû frapper un moment donné le mans
la porte à la maison des journalistes
pour demander un accueil et un
accompagnement
objectif de l'opération renvoyer spécial
sensibiliser les plus jeunes à la
liberté d'expression et aux valeurs
citoyennes
quand il parle qu'il n'y avait pas d'eau
pas de nourriture on pose la question
comment ils ont fait pour survivre
jusqu'à maintenant c'était touchant
c'est intéressant et ça va ce qu'il a
vécu lui-même
vraiment c'était mieux que par
simplement des médias la télé pour
pouvoir mieux communiquer zaher apprend
le français et l'anglais et rêve de
continuer son métier de journaliste dans
son pays natal
je veux finir mes études et je veux voir
la syrie se libérer je ne veux plus voir
de guerre je veux que les gens puissent
revenir habiter dans leur pays ou
reconstruire ce qui a été détruit et
tout refaire à nouveau depuis 2002 plus
de 400 journalistes ont été pris en
charge par la maison des journalistes